كان خالد وريم لا ينفصلان جدها كان عالمها
كله لعبتها المفضله هي سحب لحيته بينما
يسحبه شعرها لتقول ساترك اذا
[موسيقى]
تركت لا يستطيع خالد ان يتخلى عن ريمه
الصغيره يبحث الان عن ذكر وسط انقاض
منزله
عرشه ريم هذه كانت هذه دميه ريم كما
يقول كانت الاسره نائمه عندما دمرت غاره
جويه قريبه منزلهم في جنوب غزه الاسبوع
الماضي استيقظ خالد وهو يصرخ لاجل ابنائه
واحفاده يكافح من اجل المشي في الظلام
وعبر الحطام للعثور عليهم ما شفت ولا واحد
فيهم كله هذا عليهم كل الركام هذا فوق
رؤسه كانت مايسه
وفي حضنها هان عدل عدل لما شالوها الشباب
هان طون ريم وطارق هان هم الثلاثه والله
يمكن في هذا المتر لقيناهم بالكاد نجت
ابنته ميساء وشقيقتها وبعد بضعه ايام في
العنايه المركزه تتعافيان الان في منزل
احد الاقارب اول شي مش عارفه ايش اللي صار
حسيت شي ثقيل على
علي قعدت
اصرخ
صرخت
سمعت صوت ريم جنبي
بتصرخ حكت لها يا ماما مش قادره فيش تقل
علي مش قادره اعمل لك
حاجه بعدين مش عارفه ايش قلت اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله ما عرفتش ايش صار بعد هيك
استيقظت ميساء على الاخبار فارق طفليها
البالغين من العمر ثلاث وخمس سنوات الحياه
تم العثور على جثتيهما سويا تحت الانقاض
والله ناموا يومها بدري هم الاثنين ناموا
جنب
بعض احكي لهم خليكم صاحين كمان شويه م
ردوش علي قالوا لي بدنا ننام ما كانش عندي
شعور اصلا مشاعر ما عنديش كانت
قلت بس قلت لابوي هات احضنهم وانا في
المستشفى عشان اشبع منهم ما شبعت منهم قد
ما حضنتهم ما شبعتش
منهم
يا صوصي يا صوصي يا حبيبي في ايامهما
الاخيره عاشا في حرب كان اصغر من ان يفهما
لماذا لم يعد بامكانهما ارتداء اجمل
ملابسهم والخروج واللعب والحصول على
اكلاتهم المفضله مع عمل والدهما في الخارج
عاشا مع جدهما كانت ريم متعلقه جدا به
وقام بتدليل بدوره بطلبو فواكه لكن ما في
فواكه لانه انت عارف الحرب لا في فواكه
حتى الميه مش موجوده اصلا
بقيت باستمرار اجيب لهم كل انواع الفواكه
لكن في الحرب ما قدرت اجيب لهم غير كنتنا
اللي هي نوع من انواع
البرتقال امسك خالد باليوسف الذي اعطاه
لريم وذلك الذي لم تتناوله وثبت قريبا من
قلبه قرطه
الصغير ما قدرت اط انهار وهو يستذكر امسيت
هما الاخيره كيف توسل حفيدا بان ياخذ ما
للعب لكنه لم يستطع فالضرب الجويه في كل
مكان يقول خالد انه ليس مقاتلا ولم يكن
لهم اي علاقه بالحرب لكن مثل الكثير في
غزه دفعت عائلته الثمن انا لحستها مش راضي
تلحسني كل يوم تلحسني من ه بلحسها من ه
بلحسها من انفها تلحسني من انف تضحك ق
حسها من الانف بتصير تتهوى بس وانا بلحسها
وهي بتموت مش راضي
تصحى عضمت طارق ولعبته ومشط له شعره طارق
بقى يقوللي يا سيدي ابو ضياء بحب تمشط لي
تمشيطه زي في الصوره في بقت في الصوره في
صوره ولد طفل ممشط زي هيك بحب يا سيدي
اللي في كل يوم يجي يقوللي مشط لي زي اللي
في الصوره امنيتي يكونوا
يعني نايمين لكن مش نايمين في الحقيقه
كانوا كانوا
انتهوا رحلت قبل شهر من عيد ميلادها
الرابع عيد ميلاد كانت ريم تتشارك مع
جدها كانت روح الروح كما يقول
خالد كراش س
لندن